[MUSIC]
So I just want to talk about the role
that measuring plays inside of
a DevOps organization or
for a DevOps engineer.
We have an objective, we have a goal to
create some efficiency, to make some
improvement in the organization.
>From its own side that aspiration,
the aspiration to create
the change is not enough.
So even if we have the technical
capability to create something better,
we need to be able to test and verify
that we've got the result we wanted.
It's very easy to to make a claim, but
if we're going to be pragmatic in our
approach we need to test that claim and
this is where measurement
this becomes key.
We articulate the objective,
we articulate if
whatever the steps are we're going to
take to achieve that objective.
So underneath the objectives we need to
articulate the implementation steps that
we're going to take.
And then we have to ask that question,
how do I measure as measured by.
So that we can reflect at the end of
this period whether the steps that we
took actually achieve the outcome that
we wanted, and this is really critical.
When we're talking about tens of
thousands of servers in an environment,
the change propositions
that we have can have
a broad impact on our customer base.
So we need to be able to clearly measure
whether thing we're doing is actually
helping in the way that
we thought it would.
The way that I like to think about this
is we we make the value proposition or
we talk about the outcome
that we want to achieve.
We talk about the implementation
steps we're going to take and
then we ask the question how we measure
whether those steps got us to this goal.
And then when we reflect
on that we ask one or
three questions was the goal effective
or the implementation steps effective or
is it the measurements
that need to be changed.
And in this way we create a kind
of a blame free environment
which is really really critical to
fostering a strong DevOps culture.
Measurements help us to move
the conversation away from people and
onto the outcomes that we
were trying to achieve.
It's very, very easy to personalize
result especially in an environment
which we think that we carry
the cause like we're carrying
the banner for the thing.
So if you come into an organization and
you advocate strongly to take
a particular technical stance.
You could feel maybe rightfully so
that your success is tied to the success
of the power of that thing but this
can be a very dangerous place to be.
Because it colors our perception
about the work that we're doing.
It's better if we start from the
position that we have strong technical
skills.
We evaluate the situation,
we make a proposal.
I want to create a change here for
the better.
I want to increase test
coverage because I believe
that this is going to lower
defects in production.
And then I'm going to measure so
these are the steps I'm going to take
to do it, and this is how I'm going to
measure whether it's successful.
And that's going to drive
the conversation around one of
those three areas.
As opposed to a conversation
about whether I was right or
wrong about whether the thing I
did was going to have the impact
I said it was going to have.
First of all, we don't know.
I mean let's be honest,
there's a lot of variation in software.
The best software in the world
got some problems and
it's not always appropriate
in every context.
So something that worked at your
last job or something that your
friend did at another place may
work perfectly in that context but
it may not work well in
the context at your end.
And so you need to be open to taking
that feedback, to measuring the results
of what you're doing, so
that you can find the right fit.
And your advocacy is not where
your value is going to lie,
it's in your ability to assess.
The results of the thing
that you proposed or
the thing that you did that's where your
value is really going to come through.
And your values a DevOp engineer comes
from your ability to evaluate whether
the thing that you did was successful.
It is a much less to do with your
ability to identify a tool in your
environment and much more to do with
your ability to make a proposal,
execute on it, and then reflect on
how successful was that effort.
Did it hit the mark or didn't it?
That's the thing that people
are going to want from you.
You may have all sorts of
interesting opinions and
you should definitely share them
about software and about methodology.
But when it comes to execution,
you want to take a critical
data-driven approach.